[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
60 18 26 minutes d'information locale
voici les titres de ce jeudi 5 décembre
le début de la grève contre la réforme
des retraites qui a causé aujourd'hui de
nombreuses perturbations face aux
mouvements usagers des transports et
entreprises se sont organisés résultat
peu de monde ce matin sur les routes et
dans les gares reportage à suivre et le
point pour la journée de demain
le rush avant les fêtes de fin d'année a
débuté une période forcément charnière
pour l'espace saint quentin et skywest
propriété du groupe hammerson nous
parlerons avec son directeur des
animations et attentes autour de la
période et des actualités des deux
centres commerciaux
enfin c'est un noël décalé qui va
débuter à la commanderie de saint
quentin en yvelines ce week-end sur
place l encours de l'originalité des
surprises atelier vitrine et chant noël
sans oublier le sauna russe et puis une
autre idée de sortie 1,7 à voisins le
bretonneux que nous partirons à la fin
de ce journal
[Musique]
un jeudi noir annoncée pour aujourd'hui
plusieurs organisations syndicales
appelaient à une grève
interprofessionnelle contre la réforme
des retraites train bus écoles ramassage
des ordures les perturbations ont été
nombreuses comme les et comment les
usagers 1 se sont organisés face à cette
journée de perturbations le reportage ce
matin de manon par aldo et de nicolas
landry sur les routes ce matin le trafic
était fluide même très fluide sur
l'ensemble des grands axes du
département
tout le monde est sûrement partie plus
tôt mais là bas comme vous le voyez y a
personne sur la route
selon la carte en temps réel publié par
citadin à 9 heures seulement 50
kilomètres de bouchons étaient recensés
sur la région contre plus de 300 à 400
km à la même heure habituellement je
prévenais en voiture pour être sûr de
voir ne pas être pensé en fait attendre
à la gare de saint quentin en yvelines à
montigny le bretonneux seulement sept
trains circulaient entre 6 heures et 9
heures en direction de paris
les usagers se sont organisés je devais
aller à l'école argenteuil il faut pas y
aller théâtre au degré pour les 30 face
à cette grève certains yvelinois ont
opté pour des solutions de substitution
je vais en fait prendre le bus après je
vais rejoindre une collègue on va faire
du covoiturage jusqu'à la défense le
parking de la gare de la verrière
habituellement bondées est presque
désert peu d'usagers sont venus
aujourd'hui à la gare de la verrière
aucun train ne circulait je décide
depuis 5 heures du matin pour prendre le
train pour aller à paris montparnasse
mais d'après train de le rite est
tellement francs - 1° dont je dois aller
jusqu à châtillon normalement je prends
la ligne n
après le monsieur tous les bus sont
complets y laisse plus trop monter les
gens vont donc je sais pas malgré les
difficultés rencontrées certains
yvelinois soutiennent cette grève je
soutiens parce que je trouve que c'est
très important ce qu'ils entendent le
fait même pot pour eux et pour nous plus
tard aussi donc voila et pour nos
enfants aussi je suis favorable à la
grève mais vit que vu que ses revenus
je soutiens le mouvement c'est normal
les autres personnes ils vont partir
peut-être à 67 ans à la retraite
donc il faut que ça dure sans ça ça va
mal finir les voyageurs qui ont
rencontré des obstacles sur leur
parcours habituel se renseigne pour les
perturbations à prévoir de demain j'ai
pris donc les précautions davance j'ai
posé une journée de rtt
je suis à la gare pour la journée de
demain sur tout ce que l'on pense que ça
va ça va se décanter un tout petit peu
et puis nous permettent d'aller
travailler c'est tout comme
qu'est ce que je veux c'est être à mon
poste de travail quoi des assemblées
générales de grévistes se sont tenues
aujourd'hui à la ratp le syndicat unsa
qui est majoritaire annonce que les
salariés se sont prononcés sur une
reconduite de la grève jusqu'à lundi
inclus
peu ou pas de train vous l'avez vu pour
les usagers des transports avec la grève
massive annoncé la sncf a tenté de
s'organiser en maintenant un minimum de
trafic mais la consigne était tout de
même claire pour aujourd'hui
il fallait éviter d'emprunter le réseau
ferré écouté le directeur du transilien
présent hier à l'estac à montigny le
bretonneux
interrogé par mélanie potesses on a
essayé en fait sur les heures de pointe
de maintenir un certain de nos
circulation on est arrivé sur les lignes
principales a sur chaque ligne
principale à maintenir des trains en
heure de pointe
mais ça suffira pas du tout acheminer
l'ensemble des personnes qui d'habitude
on utilise les transports en commun donc
on a vraiment cette cette recommandation
d'éviter de se déplacer de et des
perturbations encore à prévoir pour
demain on fait le point tout à l'heure
face à la grève aujourd'hui il y avait
notamment la solution du covoiturage la
région ile de france a créé des
partenariats avec cinq plateformes par
niel claque site une start up créée en
2013 à saint quentin en yvelines qui est
aussi aujourd'hui installé à paris elle
continue ses partenariats avec les
entreprises de l'agglomération nicolas
landry j moins 3 avant la grève du 5
décembre les collaborateurs de claques
site prépare cette journée avec leurs
entreprises partenaires
objectif proposer des solutions de
covoiturage aux salariés pour se rendre
sur leur lieu de travail
en cas d'absence de transport en commun
on travaille aujourd'hui avec la région
ile-de-france mobilité qui vient pendant
les grèves apporter une gratuité des
trajets pour les passagers et une
indemnisation pour les conducteurs de 4
euros par passager transporté
clac ci travaille avec une dizaine
d'entreprises à saint quentin en
yvelines en règle générale 30000 trajets
sont proposés chaque jour sur le
territoire
on travaille principalement avec des
entreprises du cac 40 on compterait avec
lé principal employeur de la zone de
saint quentin en yvelines pour créer en
fait un réseau de manière à ce que
toutes les entreprises autour puisse
également qu'en voiture et facilement là
on anticipant les grèves on a préparé
des outils de communication spécifique
donc d e-mailing des supports affiches
etc de manière à ce que les entreprises
puissent communiquer directement près
leurs salariés cette start up a été créé
en 2013 elle propose des contrats aux
entreprises pour organiser un réseau de
covoiturage
depuis c'est devenu une solution en
période de mobilisation sociale
cette grève n'a pour nous rien avoir en
fait avec celle de 2018
on se rappelle un mars 2018 la grève
sncf on le ressent vraiment avec les
différents appels entrants que l'on a et
la tente qu'il y à vraiment autour des
covoiturages que l'on entre dans une
autre dimension pour nous une grève on
va dire qu'ils durent plus longtemps va
permettre justement de pousser plus de
personnes à partager leur voiture des
passagers à utiliser le covoiturage est
donc un s'inscrire aussi dans la durée
ce jeudi 5 décembre à 8h claque site
enregistré 14 fois plus de réservations
par rapport à la semaine dernière et la
plateforme de covoiturage a même
enregistré quinze mille nouveaux
inscrits sur ces deux derniers jours les
entreprises du territoire aussi se sont
préparés à cette journée du 5 décembre
un exemple antemeta à guyancourt qui a
procédé à des aménagements incitation au
télétravail flexibilité sur les horaires
est la société spécialisée dans le
stockage de données est allé même
jusqu'à payer une nuit d'hôtel à ses
salariés mathilde de me garer sur le
parking qui arrive à trouver la solution
pour ne pas rester bloqué dans les
bouchons le soir il est venu en vannes
pour jamais être pris au dépourvu
avec 95 savait que 99
plus ces épisodes neigeux sur sur guye
en cours qui sont pas neutres cette ère
que j'ai des collègues qui ont été
amenés à dormir ici donc quitte à faire
autant être autonome et pouvoir dormir
y compris sur la route pour cette
journée de grève
l'entreprise antemeta a tout prévu
télétravail nuits d'hôtel covoiturage
tout est mis à disposition pour
faciliter les déplacements des salariés
on s'est renseigné auprès de saint
quentin en yvelines auprès de la sncf
auprès même des aéroports pour contrôler
y avoir un état du trafic et ensuite on
a communiqué à nos collaborateurs
les prévisions de circulation les
prévisions de train de fermeture de
grève et écoles on leur a demandé de se
rapprocher de leur mairie dans
l'entreprise 45 employés sous tente et
travail soit plus de la moitié
même si les machines à café sont moins
sollicitées rhône on a quand même
souhaité venir grâce à l'aménagement de
son planning
la flexibilité horaire ça permet aussi
de le palier pour certains et pour moi
dans mon cas précis sur les garderies ou
les centres qui peuvent être âpre en
effectif réduit
arthur responsable informatique est
venue en voiture ce matin
et contrairement à d'habitude il n'a eu
aucun ralentissement sur la route même
s'il a pris quelques dispositions il
craint les prochains jours chez
disposition elles sont ponctuels et que
si ça continue sur plus d'une semaine je
pense qu'après ça va devenir compliqué
si la grève est reconduite l'entreprise
antemeta gardera les mêmes aménagements
pour ses salariés en cette journée de
grève contre la réforme des retraites
des bus ont été affrétés par les
syndicats afin d'acheminer les militants
aux yvelinois vers la capitale est les
différents défilés en france dans les
grandes villes ont réuni au moins à 285
mille manifestants et des actions
locales étaient également organisées à
guyancourt une vingtaine d'enseignants
s'est mobilisée dans la matinée et
devant la direction académique des
yvelines un lieu symbolique pour montrer
leur désaccord sur le projet de loi
quelques salariés du privé ont également
rejoint le mouvement les propos sont
recueillis par aurélie ans si on a fait
ce geste là aujourd'hui
ici c'est justement pour pallier à cette
problématique de transport sur paris
pour pouvoir être visible et montrer que
finalement beaucoup de gens sont pas
d'accord à cette retraite là qui nous
est annoncé tout simplement
mais je pense que tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire que pour l'instant
telle qu'elle est présentée elle n'est
pas à notre avantage ne permettrait pas
d'avoir une retraite honorable et
respectable par rapport à ce qu'on fait
à la grève qui ne fait que commencer
certains syndicats ont annoncé la
reconduction du mouvement jusqu'à lundi
les perturbations dans les transports
seront encore nombreuses demain vendredi
15 % en tout du trafic du transilien
sera assuré
aucun train ne circulera sur la ligne u
entre la défense et la verrière pour la
ligne n il y aura seulement quelques
trains en heure de pointe
15 le matin et 12 en fin de journée sur
la ligne entre paris montparnasse et
rambouillet pour les lignes de rer à
présent compter 3 trains sur 10 en
heures de pointe sur le rer à un train
sur quatre sur le rer b
enfin aucun train ne circulera sur le
rer c entre paris austerlitz et saint
quentin en yvelines
à noter que des perturbations sont
également prévues sur le réseau de bus
sur ski bus par exemple et les lignes
desservant les établissements scolaires
seront assurés en priorité j'ajoute que
de nombreuses écoles resteront encore
fermés demain l'éducation nationale
annoncée pour aujourd'hui dans
l'académie de versailles 55% de
grévistes dans les écoles notamment pour
faire face les mairies maintiennent dans
la mesure du possible leur service
d'accueil minimum
enfin des monuments comme le château de
versailles et le musée d'archéologie de
saint germain en laye ont été fermées
aujourd'hui les deux sites recommande
aux visiteurs de ne pas se rendre sur
place
également demain vendredi voilà ce qu'on
pouvait vous dire sur cette journée de
grève interprofessionnelle contre la
réforme des retraites ainsi que sur ses
conséquences dans les yvelines
[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité le rush en
vue des fêtes de fin d'année les centres
commerciaux vont recevoir beaucoup de
clients en cette période forcément
charnière bonsoir mohamed madonna risque
fort d'être le directeur de deux centres
commerciaux espace saint quentin et
skywest qui sont tous les deux à
montigny le bretonneux et et tous les
deux propriétés du groupe hammerson de
sites qui sont aussi proches
géographiquement juste pour rappeler la
stratégie des deux il y en a un qui est
orienté vers le shopping et l'autre sur
le de l'offre plus culturelle plus de
divertissement c'est absolument donc
espace saint quentin qui historiquement
est la destination shopping qu'on
connaît depuis maintenant le 87 et
skywest qui du coup va dans le
prolongement de l'espace saint quentin
et de ce qui se fait aujourd'hui dans
les centres commerciaux et qui du coup
deviendra la destination shopping et e
et loisirs du bassin de
montigny-le-bretonneux tout ça pour
créer un pôle unique shopping loisirs et
restauration
mais on va parler de deux actualités
deux arrivées dans des ces deux centres
commerciaux déjà comment vous aborder
cette période des fêtes de fin d'année
le rush là qui débute en ce mois de
décembre lors ce qui est important pour
nous dans cette période là c'est
d'offrir avant tout à nos clients une
expérience une expérience shopping
différente de d'habitude
et aujourd'hui ce sont les looney toons
qui seront mis à l'honneur sur l'espace
50 ans et skywest donc les clients ont
la possibilité de croiser pour les plus
chanceux les fameux personnages de
cartoon que tout le monde connaît comme
bugs bunny taz titi et gros minet par
exemple des animations autour des looney
tunes pour procéder à cette période de
fin d'année
forcément une période charnière quelles
sont vos attentes on note dans le moi
bien évidemment le plus important le
plus important de l'année aussi bien en
chiffre d'affaires qu'en en visiteurs
donc du coup c'est toutes les équipes
des magasins et les équipes qui nous
permettent de faire fonctionner le
centre commercial qui se mettent en
ordre de marche pour répondre à cette
demande qui du coup va tripler sur cette
période j'ai combien le visiteur ans
en moyenne sur sur cette période sur la
période du mois de décembre on va
dépasser le million de visiteurs au très
largement alors l'actualité des deux
centres commerciaux elle est riche déjà
en fin de semaine dernière c'est terminé
scola la deuxième édition de scola c'est
une boutique écoles qui étaient
implantés au sein de l'espace saint
quentin pour former aux métiers de la
vente votre bilan quel est-il on a fait
le bilan avec les les personnes qui ont
été formés sur place le bilan côté
espace saint quentin
alors déjà l'objectif de ce type de
d'animation pardon c'est de
d'accompagner le dynamisme économique du
territoire et l'insertion
professionnelle donc c'est une vingtaine
de jeunes qui ont intégré ce programme
de formation est l'idée est
d'accompagner déjà un lait les besoins
des enseignes en préparant des jeunes en
insertion professionnelle pour le sur
les métiers de la vente et de deux
d'accompagner ces jeunes vers un nouveau
métier mais qui n'avaient pas forcément
en objectifs
il ya quelques années par exemple mais
l'an passé ses jeunes de scola avait pu
travailler au sein des magasins de
l'espace saint quentin pendant la
période de noël on sait que les
enseignes sont sont recrutés en cette
période
est ce que ça sera le cas également
cette année c'est le cas encore cette
année là il est encore un peu tôt pour
en parler parce qu'ils viennent juste de
terminer leur formation mais ils ont
entamé les quinze jours de stage à
l'issue de leur formation théorique et
la moitié de ces de ces jeunes ont
intégré le centre commercial dans
l'actualité de l'espace 50 a nié une
rumeur aussi qui a circulé récemment
c'est le départ de l'enseignent h&m est
ce que c'est une rumeur infondée un
schème restera bien à l'espace important
je rassure tout le monde c'est une
rumeur totalement infondée
alors je ne sais pas d'où provient cette
rumeur mais une seule personne
aujourd'hui ne peut vous donner ces
informations et c'est bien moi et je
rassure tout le monde
h m n'est pas sur le départ et restent
sur espace saint quentin
tout comme les grandes enseignes
emblématiques comme sephora gosses morts
c'est à qui du coup aujourd'hui sont sur
espace 50 ha ils le resteront alors une
dernière actualité on va parler d'abord
de skywest avec une nouvelle offre de
divertissement i way qui va arriver de
la réalité virtuelle on pourra faire
aussi de la simulation sur formule 1 et
et rallye c'est ça highway qui ouvrira
courant janvier 2001 donc comme vous
lighting une en 5,3 à la simulation de
vote
et ce quelle game et réalité virtuelle
basique fit une salle de sport aussi sur
près de 2000 m² pour janvier en sur la
partie skywest et sur espace 50 ans la
bolivie d'un bowling sur près de 2000 m²
15 pistes de bowling la maison papé et
comptoirs de mathilde qui offriront
premier trimestre 2010 2020 pardon on
souhaite bon courage
cette charnière des fêtes de fin d'année
merci mohamed madounari j'en passe vous
êtes directeur de deux centres
commerciaux l'espace saint quentin et
skywest un tous deux propriétés du
groupe hammerson
on sait depuis le 18 novembre le projet
de réaménagement du carrefour de la
malle me donne est en concertation sur
les trois communes concernées à savoir
la verrière maurepas et coignières hier
soir se tenait justement à coignières
une réunion de travail un atelier de
travail plus précisément vous y étiez
maryland à pishin au bon soir au sein de
la rédaction de tv 78 est-ce que vous
pouvez déjà revenir sur ce projet weir
et gorille alors ce fameux carrefour de
la maille me donne c'est un projet qui
ne date pas d'hier et bien d'une
quarantaine d'années car cette zone
située vraiment à l'intersection des
trois communes que vous avez cités pose
bien des problèmes notamment de sécurité
je rappelle que des accidents mortels
ayant eu lieu
on écoute didier fischer le maire de
coignières le maire que je suis est
plutôt satisfait en effet que l'état ait
repris à son compte ce projet et qui
nous propose aujourd'hui une
concertation publique sur le sujet mais
il est évident qu'il faut en
contrepartie que les habitants aussi
soit entendu que les commerçants soient
entendus pour faire le projet gelé dire
le plus
réalisa possible mais le plus en
adéquation avec ce que nous souhaitons
alors que prévoit ce projet car déjà il
répond à plusieurs objectifs de renfort
des liaisons entre les secteurs au nord
et au sud de la rn10 d'amélioration et
de sécurisation des conditions de
déplacement pour les piétons les
cyclistes et les personnes à mobilité
réduite
sans oublier les commerces et les
entrées de ville en améliorant l'accès
ou participent au développement
alors concrètement vous allez le voir
sur la carte la rn10 serait dénivelé
avec par dessus un pont en orange pour
permettre la liaison entre la rd 13
c'est la rd 213 avec deux voies de
circulation dans chaque sens et un
trottoir envers la mise en place des
deux carrefours à feux pour permettre le
maintien des bretelles entre les voix
qui sont en rose
enfin le démontage de la passerelle
piétonne existantes et vous l'avez dit
il avait lu un atelier de travail dans
le cadre de la concertation je vous
propose d'écouter les réactions
d'habitants et commerçants du secteur
moi je suis installé au bord de
nationale 10 et embêter tous les jours
par la circulation et puis
l'accessibilité qui est quand même très
très dangereuse je pense que c'est un
pansement sur une jambe de bois
parce que finalement si l'enfouissement
qu'il aurait fallu ya des quelque chose
des quelques modifications que peut
apporter ça c'est sûr parce que
comme on vit ici on voit bien ce qui se
passe et on a fait quelques propositions
on va voir si on en tient compte et you
are et amène un réaménagement qui était
attendu par les habitants et choses
importantes qui peuvent donner leur avis
sur le projet alors c'est effectivement
tout l'objet de cette concertation
elle est encadrée par un quart en au
titre de l'article l100 3 2 du code de
l'urbanisme
introduit par la loi du 12 juillet 1985
relative à la définition et à la mise en
oeuvre de principes d'aménagement
mon rôle dans une concertation c'est de
m'assurer que de la bonne information du
public et de la qualité de l'information
qui lui est fourni pour faire en sorte
que chacun puisse s'exprimer et de
veiller effectivement à ce que les
modalités de la concertation permette
cette expression et permettent que
l'avis des participants soient prises en
compte
une réunion publique de restitution des
travaux menés par les habitants se
tiendra le 12 décembre à maurepas
mais la concertation continue jusqu'au
20 décembre vous pouvez retrouver toutes
les informations sur le site de la
direction des routes d'ile-de-france et
vous exprimer par mail voie postale sur
les registres papier mis à disposition
dans les trois mairies le calendrier en
train qu'elle est il alors si le projet
validé les travaux devraient débuter en
2023 pour deux ans avec l'inauguration
espérée en 2026 coût total des travaux
20 millions d'euros
merci marylène pour ces précisions ça
fait un an qu'elle est installé dans les
nouveaux quartiers des chantiers à
versailles nous avait quitté ses anciens
locaux de saint quentin en yvelines la
caf des yvelines a inauguré
officiellement hier ses nouveaux locaux
l'organisme privé qui gère le versement
des aides sociales et familiales et
dispose de six mille mètres carrés
d'espacé pour ses 300 collaborateurs un
accès plus simple à deux pas de la gare
des chantiers un accueil du public
repenser 8 box dédiée au rendez-vous un
espace numérique fonctionnel avec 24
postes en libre accès pour effectuer ces
démarches à l'extérieur enfin une borne
interactive pour consulter son dossier
allocataires à tout moment les propos
sont repris par patrick jacques de
dixmude
nous avons choisi cette date
anniversaire pour accueillir nos
partenaires et puis effectivement
souligné toute la qualité de vie que
nous avons depuis que nous sommes ici
depuis un an
donc qualité de vie d'accueil pour nos
allocataires ce sont plus de 16000
personnes qui sont qui ont été
accueillis à la caf des yvelines depuis
depuis un an
nous sommes pleinement dans notre
logique d'accessibilité pour nous pour
nos publics avec un accueil totalement
rénové moderne et en conformité avec la
stratégie d'accueil des allocataires
c'est à dire du rendez vous mais
également de l'accès libre à des espaces
de multimédia comme tous les jeudis les
idées de sorties du week end mélanie
poker dans quelques instants vous nous
parlerait d'une exposition à voisins le
bretonneux mais d'abord d'abord armelle
au brier bonsoir sans vous êtes la 7e
vice présidente de saint quentin en
yvelines en charge de la culture et à
l'évaluation des politiques publiques à
la commanderie à partir de samedi c'est
un noël pas comme les autres qui est
proposée le noël des cas laissé jusqu'au
19 décembre sur le site localisé à
elancourt pourquoi fêter noël autrement
parce que les les compétences et de la
commanderie c'est l'image que
saint-quentin donc c'est l'innovation
c'est la création
donc en fait c'est ce qui marche qu'on
veut développer mais en gardant des
idées de la fête noël des relations
familiales
en fait on aussi noël autrement on nous
apprend à faire par exemple des paquets
cadeaux avec du tissu à noël plus
écologique en fait et il va déjà y avoir
une exposition donc comme vous l'avez
dit qu'il va commencer le samedi 7
décembre et qui dure jusqu'au dimanche
22 décembre de 14h à 18h et en même
temps il a ce sera la vitrine donc la
vitrine de noël on retrouve ça partout
mais à partir de création de fabrique de
père noël automatique et tout ça fait
avec des des artistes et des et des
jeunes étudiants puisque c'est supporter
aussi par ses idées par l'université
et puis en même temps on aura la ferme
de noël avec les avec les animaux donc
la tradition la création au milieu d'eux
au milieu de tout ça il y aura le
week-end 17 18 et 19 décembre
des chorales
viendront chanter des chants adapté donc
de noël mais venant aussi de tous les
horizons et de tous les styles de
culture et puis on aura un marché de
noël le 14 et le 15
décembre et là on fera la part belle aux
créateurs locaux
on a vu aussi l'arbre à mohon qui
proposait aussi chaque année ça ça fait
partie du fil conducteur pictures rade
depuis le sec depuis le sec jusqu'au 22
22 décembre mais aussi à l'intérieur de
ce noël dès qu'il ya un festival noël
ensemble
c'est ça avec plusieurs en fait il y à
dents dans le week-end au moment du
marché de noël le 14 et le 15 il y aura
un bal le samedi soir de 19h à 21h et là
aussi ça sera de la danse pour tous mais
en fait aussi tous les styles
mais effectivement tout le monde tout le
monde pourra participer du plus jeune
plus aux plus âgés et j'ai lu qu'il y
avait un sauna russes aussi proposé dit
moïse en plus il sera préservé parce qu
il est
c'est dans une roulotte donc il est pas
très grand et puis au milieu de tout ça
il y aura des à payer comme vous l'avez
cité tout à l'heure le furoshiki là les
emballages les emballages qui sont
marqués de pliage et de et de noeuds il
y aura des ateliers durant toute cette
période de réserve et pour tous les âges
il faut s'y inscrire donc toutes les
informations et tous les renseignements
notamment pour un s'inscrire sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci en mélo brié vice-présidente de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en charge
notamment de la culture l'école pour
certains ce sont de mauvais souvenirs
pour d'autres de bons souvenirs mais on
a tous des souvenirs de nos moments
passés en classe ou en cours de
récréation il certaine nostalgie que
vous pouvez revivre à voisins le
bretonneux depuis le 30 novembre on en
parle avec vous mais les nippes ok bon
soit bon ça c'est votre rendez-vous
loisirs ouais c'est même un vraiment bon
madeleine de proust même les plus jeunes
peuvent être touchés par cette
exposition les grands parents les
parents peuvent ainsi faire découvrir
comment c'était pour eux à l'école on
retrouve les plumes les buvards les
fameuses leçons de morale aussi les
blues alors mais l'école actuelle est
aussi bien représenté puisque on peut
découvrir les pn il
me tableau numérique interactif où le
robot nao
l'exposition a été pensé par le club des
collectionneurs des yvelines avec la
ville de voisins-le-bretonneux un mot du
président tous les objets qui sont dans
cette classe sont d'époque
seuls les tables pédagogiques ont été
reconstitués afin effectivement de
permettre à l'ensemble des visiteurs et
des étudiants ou écoliers de comprendre
l'évolution de l'école
nous voulions montrer ce qu'était une
école en 1900 et surtout montré
également comment évoluent évoluer
l'école depuis les années on va dire
depuis la création d'écoles jusqu'aux
années d'aujourd'hui où aujourd'hui on
parle beaucoup de numérique alors
l'exposition est à découvrir jusqu'au 18
décembre à la maison de kovy grégory
c'est une très jolie plongée dans
l'histoire écolières et on peut même se
tester à l'écriture avec la plume et ça
vaut le coup merci mélanie pour cette
idée de sortie dans un instant on vous
retrouve à la présentation du 7-8
loisirs avec d'autres idées de sorties à
faire ce week-end c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de l'avoir suivi belle
soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]